sportlerehrung einmal anders anfang der
woche wird der steirische heeressportler
vinzenz hakt ins
verteidigungsministerium in wien geladen
warum weiß er allerdings nicht das
natürlich sehr überrascht dass sie mich
aus einer empfangen hat sind dann also
die stadt gesehen hat habe ich schon die
abend warum das ganze etwas zu sagen
denn diese statue kennt er schon seit
2014 da wird erstmals steirischer
sportler des jahres ist einer unserer
sportler auf dem heutigen tag ganz
besonders stolz sind das land steiermark
ihn zum sportler des jahres 2020 gemacht
hat gerade der turnsport ist vielleicht
einer der nicht so im medialen fokus
steht umso schöner ist es dass die
entscheidung auf unseren körper gefallen
ist und er zeigt damit auch wie wichtig
unsere lehre sportlerinnen und sportler
sind wir haben ja über 300
spitzenathletinnen und spitzenathleten
im einsatz und die sind alle sehr froh
darauf endlich wieder trainieren zu
können
ganz besondere gratulation freut mich
besonders dass wir das in diesem umfang
zustande bekommen in den vergangenen
jahren steigt höchst sportliche
leistungskurve kontinuierlich nach oben
weltcup bronze und silber
junioren-europameister gesamt weltcup
zweiter und dritter platz um nur einige
erfolge zu nennen
2014 weil im juniorenbereich und habe
mich dort sozusagen etabliert dann bin
ich in den erwachsenenbereich gekommen
und der schritt von von junioren und
erwachsen ist in jeder sportart die ganz
im großen theater und seine fünf jahre
gekämpft und letztes jahr habe ich meine
erfolgreichste saison bislang zeichnen
können
und da ist das erste mal gemerkt dass
sich sozusagen den anschluss fast ganz
nach oben jetzt auch bei den erwachsenen
bei den ganzen großen geschafft habe und
es gibt natürlich viel kraft motivation
dass man weitermacht im in naher zukunft
auch einmal ganz oben zu stehen
die überraschung ist uns gelungen und es
ist gerade in zeiten wie diesen auch
notwendig ganz besondere momente auch zu
erzeugen auf den jetzigen und auf die
augen von winterberg war ich besonders
gespannt und auch sehr erfreut darüber
eine überraschung die uns gemeinsam mit
der sporthilfe die wir so viele jahre
lang unser partner ist und gemeinsam
auch mit dem land steiermark mit dem
landesrat christopher drexler perfekt
gelungen ist
[Musik]